tonight's show will start with the
comedy stylings
of hans kim hans kim is the next
first on kill tony
oh here we go hans is moving fast this
could be one of those cases where the
comedian is out of breath immediately
upon the start of their set he decided
to sprint through the room here we go
here's hans kim everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's up guys my name is hans kim
a lot of the ladies that i date like to
call me a premature ejaculator
which is ridiculous because premature to
who
okay i came right at the perfect time
when i felt amazing
it takes maturity to know how to please
yourself
um a lot of i'm an asian man
a lot of asian women they act like
they're better than asian men because
they're sexier than us
but uh we look exactly the same okay why
are you bragging
i could throw on a wig and be a seven
relax
braggingly you can [ __ ] white dudes i
can [ __ ] white dudes
we can all [ __ ] away dudes
a lot of people make fun of asians
because we like to eat dogs
which i understand is very shocking
because in america dogs are treated like
family members but
in asia we treat our family members like
family members
[Applause]
wow what a great set great start to the
night
hans kim hell yeah
even bows like an asian man look at that
that is
incredible [ __ ] yeah
welcome to the show hans thank you tony
how long you been doing stand up
eight years [ __ ] yeah man it really
shows i love it
i love it when people with real comedy
experience that are really good at this
show
sign up because look what happens people
get to [ __ ] find you and you kill and
it feels good right
yeah it feels amazing hell yeah i watch
this show all the time
i love it man are you born and raised in
austin no i'm from uh seattle and new
york
okay both of them which one first
how long were you in new york three
years okay and that's when you started
stand up
i started in seattle for five and then
moved to new york for my graduate
program oh so asian of you
[Laughter]
what did you study in your graduate
program
um open mics in brooklyn and uh
performing for comedians
who are angry how about how about for
the school part
oh when you study oh mechanical
engineering and georgia tech
wow my goodness do you use that degree
for anything what do you do for work now
i um i live in a van so i i'm uh
i'm unemployed and uh yeah i don't
really do that that's uh that's my old
life
i love it wow so cool i absolutely love
this
it's so unasian to uh abandon your
degree
what do your parents think about this
choice that you've made they're uh
they're trying to be like progressive
asians they're like the new
kind of you know oh the new asians all
right yeah i've seen the new
i've seen the new line from honda it's
very uh
very sleek progressive
you look so much like my girlfriend i
love it
i'm just imagining you with like long
hair now you're like you're so right
yeah you really painted the picture for
red band
hard as a rock right now i love it derek
what do you think about this guy
bro that was a great set dog thank you
the training thing was the
throw the wig on that was great i like
[ __ ] porn so i was feeling you bro
you look good okay thank you
who doesn't love [ __ ] porn right i
mean i don't
okay anyway uh
i do like training porn or transgender
porn when it's
like like it's a girl with tits with a
dick
[ __ ] a normal girl though yeah you
know what i mean i've always said that's
straighter than a guy that looks like a
guy
banging a chick yeah all these homos out
here watching
dudes [ __ ] chicks [ __ ] that [ __ ]
i love it what kind of what's your
favorite kind of porn what's what's your
sneaky type of you seem like the kind of
guy that would be into a
you know like a step grandmother or
something like that
he's definitely toilet porn right no i'm
into tickling man
oh the red band goes wild over here
my goodness what are we talking about
like what's your perfect scent like
what's your favorite porn like what did
that look like a guy just
like his pillow explodes and feathers
her everywhere
i don't really i can't really get into
tickle porn
yeah not really my thing at all i'm into
more like uh
like not like whatever the opposite
you should watch tickle point though
like when somebody's really ticklish and
they're like getting tickle tortured and
then they're getting [ __ ] at the same
time it's like
it's craziness oh that sounds that
sounds fake
no who can who can laugh and really get
[ __ ] at the same time like one of
those things
isn't working if you're really ticklish
it works wow are you ticklish
yes
just ignore the tickle stick in his
pants
hans what do you like to do for fun you
do have any asian hobbies karaoke
or collecting salt and pepper shakers
perhaps
i'm into uh basketball i like starcraft
2
a real-time strategy game
keep going no it's okay tell us more i
uh
i'm into um watching a lot of podcasts
uh i'm into living in my van like
finding a good place to go to the
bathroom
is pretty exciting yeah that's that is a
challenge how long have you lived in the
van for
about three years in new york and then
here how long have you been
in austin about two weeks okay cool
where do you park it
uh by zilker wow
lady bird there you go are you here for
good now
uh until i you know it's like i'm so
transitory it's hard to say but yeah i
mean several months i love austin so i'm
trying to stay here because it's like
popping off
i have a show wednesday at a vulcan gas
company i'd love to have you on thank
you very much
oh look at that he just booked a spot on
a
real show hell yeah what a way to start
the night huh
what are you gonna do after this what
are you gonna do to celebrate i'm gonna
go upstairs and be like haha
[ __ ] you know
wow look at that strut my stuff a bit
and then go to um the blind pig for
another open mic
there you go oh yeah all right
absolutely you did it man that's exactly
how it's done you come in you do jokes
my favorite part
was when you said i'm an asian man
i know you said that at some point
those words came out of your mouth in
that order i'm an asian man
everyone was like oh no
i was like look at this [ __ ] before he
said that look at this
strong black man he's got a spot on
wednesday
you found him here ladies and gentlemen
one more time for hans kim
everybody wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
stop stop stop stop
why is your twitter hold on hold on wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait
why is your twitter handle dj hans kim
are you a dj
no i just thought it was funny like you
know
like who it's like the same thing dj
comedian
you're right it works there he goes dj
hans kim on twitter
and probably instagram
i was gonna say very rarely do you see
an asian dj